we're gonna turn now to some royal knew
anything about the Royal says when is
that baby coming any moment now and
Megan and Harry are determined to do it
their own way here's a look at
everything we know about Megan's birth
plan thus far I think Megan is really
working out a birth plan that best suits
her with the advice of her doctor don't
expect to be Megan bolo in Kate
Middleton or Princess Diana's footsteps
after the birth of her royal babe the
perfect hair the red carpet worthy
makeup and the gorgeous designer dress
just hours after giving birth or
learning Megan isn't having any of that
Harry and Megan will not be posing
outside the hospital leaving after the
birth of their baby they plan to release
a couple of photographs to the media a
couple of days after the baby is born a
source tells ET that Megan doesn't want
the pressure of having to pose on the
steps for cameras so soon after
childbirth she simply doesn't want the
pressure of having to look photo
fabulous after she's just had a baby in
2013 a sighting of chief stylist and
hairdresser entering the hospital was
our first clue that the Duchess of
Cambridge had given birth to Prince
George but with no official post baby
photo op for Megan no glam squad is
needed so how will we know when baby
Sussex has arrived the Queen will be the
first to find out about the baby news
that's in accordance with royal
tradition but as for everyone else well
we'll just have to wait
according to a statement from the palace
but Duke and Duchess look forward to
sharing the exciting news with everyone
once they have had an opportunity to
celebrate privately as a new family I
think Harry in making a very keen to
maintain maximum privacy for their child
are moving forward well it here's what
Megan and Harry are allowing once Megan
is in labor as we understand right now
the media is going to be allowed on the
Long Walk that was the long stretch
where the carriage procession took place
during Harry and Megan's carriage
procession following the wedding called
up Megan and Harry got married at st.
George's Chapel in Windsor but Kate and
Diana both gave birth to their children
in the Lindo wing of st. Mary's Hospital
in London the two locations are about an
hour drive apart so where is Megan
planning to give birth we don't think
that Megan will give birth in the same
hospital where Kate gave birth where
Diana gave birth according to reports
earlier this year the Duchess was
considering delivering at friendly Park
Hospital in Surrey near the couple's
home at Frogmore cottage and she may
deliver in the comfort of her own home
there's been a lot of talk that megan is
wants to have a home birth but I think
Megan is also going to be making all of
these decisions on the advice of her
doctors she is 37 which does post
slightly higher risks from our
first-time pregnancy
wherever baby's buttocks debut were
pretty positive that Megan will opt for
the most healthy and natural options
possible she's been fit well healthy on
every engagement she's appeared to be
really energetic and people are
crediting that to her yogurt regimen and
Meg will be surrounded by the best of
the best
there's been talk of her using a doula
and according to reports the Duchess may
have snubbed the Queen's doctors opting
instead to hire her own 20-person
delivery team led by a female MD another
report claims medics have been on call
24 hours a day and are banned from booze
until baby Sussex is born listen each
other know something it's in your
chapter right but no matter what it
sounds like the royal family is on board
walls are very driven by duty there is
an expectation in terms of what they do
in their public lives but when it comes
to their private lives
everyone is incredibly supportive